it's been more than three decades since
Anita Hill helped change the way our
country views sexual harassment it was
back in 1991 she was a young attorney
and professor and she testified that her
former boss and then Supreme Court
nominee Clarence Thomas sexually
harassed her the visuals are
Unforgettable she was speaking to an
all-white male Senate panel during his
Supreme Court nomination hearings Thomas
denied wrongdoing and went on to serve
on the nation's highest court where he
is still today Hill has since then
dedicated her career to fighting
gender-based violence her book believing
our 30-year journey to end gender
violence is out in paperback today and
Anita Hill joins us now thank you so
much for being here thank you for having
me I will say that the hardback had your
picture on the cover and I think that
led some people to think it was a memoir
or something but in fact there are
personal stories here but really it's
about the bigger fight so it's about the
bigger fight and the fight that is
ongoing and has been for 30 years and
has been evolving
um you know we are not where we were 30
years ago when I testified people didn't
even know that there was such a thing as
sexual harassment and then the people
who knew about it didn't know that it
was against the law they didn't know
what they could do about it they didn't
know what they could do about it even
though it was against the law so we have
advanced from there but the way I see
the problem now after 30 years in the
literally tens of thousands of people
who have contacted me about their
experiences the way I see it now is that
it's a bigger problem than we ever
imagined 30 years you liking it to
Boiling the ocean trying to get your
arms around it to understand it what do
we need to be doing differently as a
country well as a country I think we've
moved forward culturally we've learned
more we have better knowledge
nevertheless I think where we are right
now uh is that we know there's a problem
we say we're against it right but when
it comes down to it and we have to act
we're not necessarily ready to hold
people accountable and I mean even hold
our institutions accountable again all
of that is changing and evolving but
we're still leaving too many
opportunities for people to abuse folks
in the workplace uh and as I say this is
a very inclusive problem it leaves us to
uh where people are young people are
being raped on college campus is
sexually assaulted on college campuses
um there's not enough response to it we
are still dealing with problems with
intimate partner violence which during
the pandemic Sky High rocketed and there
was just not enough we're just not
enough facilities to deal with and house
the people
who were left homeless because you say
there's no longer enough to say we don't
discriminate against women because we do
no longer okay to say we don't know the
facts but we'll make decisions without
the facts no longer okay to say he said
she said excuse and do nothing so but
you said this is a period of Reckoning
it's not a marathon now you say you say
it's a relay
well it is a relay and and what I mean
by that is that you know I thought it
would be over a lot so are you amazed 30
years later you were still talking about
this oh I I I I am amazed it wasn't part
of my life plan uh and I thought really
or very early on that what would happen
was that we would find the right
processes and the right procedures and
people would and the right leaders and
people would you know bring their
complaints and the law would change well
not only the law has been very slow to
react and and even in 2013 Ruth bad
againstburg said that she felt that her
colleagues were on this unrestained
unrestrained course to actually limit
the protections to Corral the
protections so we have we've made some
progress of course but there's still so
much to go and we've we have to look at
our systems and that's and speaking of
that I want to ask you about those
systems um you talk about in the book
how gender violence is enriched in the
Health Care system in offices even in
schools and we have to change the way we
educate the youth what do you mean by
that yeah I
I picked one place to start it would be
how we teach our children about the
issues that use children not teenagers
not young adults children children I
mean we give children wrong messages
girls and boys girls and boys we tell
girls that if a boy picks on them teases
them pinches them pulls their bra straps
or pulled down their pants it's because
they like them and what we're doing is
we're setting them up and it's boys
being boys and that's the way they are
and that's where we're we're grooming
them essentially for abuse later abuse
and we're really grooming the boys to
say that the only appropriate behavior
is abusive and aggressive behavior and
it doesn't disservice to both uh the
girls and the boys and you know and and
we then know that the problem gets
exacerbated when we have non-binary
youth
um who are dealing with these issues
because of the way that they express
their gender so this is a big problem
start with children it affect all of us
and it affects us which is why you have
the term gender violence it's all
encompassing uh Anita Hill thank you
very much the paperback edition of
believing it is on sale now it's very
good pick it up we'll be right back